you're in the new song that's a big deal
so tell me about that experience getting
the call and have you started shooting
yet yeah we actually just wrapped a
couple weeks ago we shot for about six
weeks in Toronto I had an amazing time
Chris Rock is a phenomenal co-star I've
had I mean I had so much fun you'd think
you would think with the dark content of
saw that this would be like a very
serious set it couldn't have been more
opposite just goofy and happy and you
know your dead body is in broken arms
and this one that the other and we had a
blast we had a great time it really does
I mean I I it was really kind of freeing
I think it was just such a different
character than when I play on Riverdale
yeah and I loved diving into that and
then like I mentioned Chris was amazing
I worked with Sam which was like you
know Sam Jackson what surprised you
about being on the set with those two
beside for humor what else surprised you
know it sounds silly but maybe the
collaboration the willingness to
collaborate the willingness at the end
of the day to just make sure you get a
good product
I love that you know and that I find
with any guy that's sort of hopefully at
the top of their game they're willing to
collaborate they just want to make a
good a good scene a good show career now
coming off you know you're still doing
Riverdale you got saw going on
you see these doors opening right and
what is exciting you about the
possibilities
no I mean I love telling stories yeah I
love being a part of I love being a part
of things that people love to watch to
embrace I've been very lucky with
Riverdale and then to jump into the saw
series that has a huge following I
really enjoy that at the same time it's
kind of pressure a little bit of
pressure I'm not gonna lie but you're
right you said it it opens up doors and
it allows me to hopefully tell more
stories play different roles work with
other people that I admire you know
within my field Riverdale is obviously
based on the Archie stuff which is kind
of nerdy geeky comic-book stuff as well
saw obviously horror has it has its fans
as well what are you into geek wise are
you into anything are you one of those
cool girls I read every night before I
go to bed so it's constant constant
science fiction books I just you're
watching anything now that's like a geek
wise or sup how are you into the MCU at
all I mean I'm more reading and reading
all the time I watched on planes okay
that's what I watched um what is
something you want to do next
like what is the style of film as genre
film you want to next look anybody in my
business is gonna say Marvel anybody
right because the paycheck and they and
the idea of playing a superhero is
really really cool for me it's it's I'm
not gonna say no but I like playing a
character that has a story I like
playing broken characters I like playing
characters that don't start out broken
and then becoming broken I like a
challenge I think probably just like any
other performer but I enjoy that sort of
thing the hero is really really fun but
if I'm gonna play the hero I'd like it
to be a struggling yeah i struggling
here so you see this happening now more
and more of these sci-fi geeky superhero
stuff are exploring trauma and PTSD and
mental health stuff does that excite you
as an actress not because that's being
taught not because that's something to
exploit because that's something is
being talked about honestly it is it is
I think any science fiction fantasy
they're all sort of embracing this new
movement and it's all just sort of very
collaborative and I really like that
it's very inclusive it seems like that's
the kind of roles you'll be doing next
so thank you so much for your time